mosaic one of the things that's amazing
about this project and I'm surprised
someone hasn't done this before is you
can choose alternate endings there's the
show itself now there's an app where
people watching it can confuse on an
Apple you can go on you can buy the
mosaic app and it starts with what would
essentially be the pilot and then it
comes down and there's like a couple
it's a little like your fake looks like
a family tree kind of thing and you
choose it because it's a murder mystery
and essentially the audience which is
you become the detectives and as you go
through it you can solve the mystery by
following this this branching narrative
in the way that you choose to do it and
it's it's awesome what I was all about
it and then it's gonna be on HBO this
week every night yes in a linear format
you can choose I just have to get one
word in here yeah I know you're so proud
of it but yeah but you know it says
Conan on the show just yelled at Sharon
Stone yeah that's how I was during our
difficult breakup but what I love is
that you can see the front you can take
the perspective of different characters
- so you see things through their
perspective at their point of view if
you and and I think that I've been
waiting because we live in this digital
era for someone to crack that and start
making entertainment that way because
that's how that's how young people
experience video games and narrative
lines is choosing these different paths
yeah it's beautiful and and I would
imagine that you'd have to shoot a lot
more than a normal project besides twist
you have to cover so much 500 pages 500
page script yeah okay absolutely
unbelievably have a clip here from
mosaic do you know which clip this is I
do it is the script where I try to pick
up one of my co-stars Garrett Hedlund at
the bar let's take a look it was like oh
I like take a look at this clip from
Isaiah
for me something tall and muscular
you got it
a lesser nuanced host - headstand
okay Cupid you're on - yeah I think I'm
being played off
[Music]
you are thank you
I'm sorry I know you probably get this a
lot no I know a little old for
children's author
you might be the reason I became an
artist
[Music]
no woman's ever looked at me that way in
my entire life what you just staring
right at them for so long oh my god oh I
like that that's nice very nice
[Applause]
I think you can see in this exchange why
I always blew it in these situations
[Laughter]
you